habituellement c'est dans les zones très
nordiques du continent qu'on peut
admirer des aurores boréales mais pour
une rare fois c'est beaucoup plus au sud
du Canada qu'on peut les voir au Québec
c'est au Saguenay et dans le body fleuve
où les amateurs en ont eu plein la vue
ces derniers jours l'activité est si
intense dernièrement la queue on a
vraiment le temps de en tant que
photographe de parcourir des lieux
différents toujours avec un ciel qui est
sous les aurores boréales avec des
couleurs différentes des dynamiques
vraiment super intéressantes ce sont les
violentes tempêtes qui ont lieu à la
surface du Soleil qui sont à l'origine
des aurores boréales en ce moment même
notre étoile produit d'immenses boules
d'énergie qui est expulse du placement
et des particules qui viennent entrer en
collision avec l'atmosphère de la Terre
depuis le début de cette année on est
dans la partie ascendante donc plus
d'orages
magnétique à la surface du Soleil qui
viennent perturber de champ magnétique
terrestres et la haute atmosphère de
notre planète donc qui provoque plus
d'aurores boréales des horaires plus
intenses visibles sur de plus de crâne
par partie du territoire selon les
spécialistes les deux tâches géantes que
l'on voit ici vont faire sentir leurs
effets pendant encore quelques jours
c'était visible hier probablement ce
soir peut-être demain et puis il faut
pas s'en faire si jamais la météo ne
collabore pas on va pouvoir se rattraper
dans les semaines dans les mois qui
suivent parce que le cycle est en
croissance donc sur une période à peu
près deux ou trois ans on devrait
assister à beaucoup de rares boréales
particulièrement au sud du pays
évidemment une grande ville illuminée
comme Montréal n'est pas l'endroit rêvé
pour observer des aurores boréales mais
pas très loin en périphérie c'est tout à
fait possible donc on va sortir des
villes on va essayer d'avoir une vue
bien dégagée sur le nord un ciel sans
nuage et après c'est la nature qui fait
son spectacle
c'est normal Grondin Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Musique]